I'm gonna be talking about that our CEO
per launcher and how this can change or
help change where we run our stuff so
what is the launcher the launcher will
allow applications in this case we're
talking about house show server Pro to
easily launch jobs and in this case
we're talking about our jobs somewhere
now this sounds pretty simple but it
opens up some interesting use cases I'd
like to show you some of the cool things
it allows you to do so I thought I'd
start off with an example of how I've
used launcher then we can dive in more
into the details of how it actually
works so the last our studio conference
I saw yours talk on five packages in
five weeks you might have been there in
it he mentions a post about creating
portraits with text using our so here's
a portrait of Hadley made entirely of
deep wire code I read through his posts
and I thought it was interesting so
before this conference I thought it'd be
cool to create the same kind of
portraits with all the our studio
employees and conference speakers using
what Twitter profiles I had access to so
I get working on my script I'm doing
this work on our CI server Pro
connecting using a browser it doesn't
take that long because I have all the
pieces I just need to put it together it
does take some time to run though it
downloads all the text and images it
does some transformation to it and then
it plots the text to create the image
and it does is one at a time so wait for
it to finish and then I have my
beautiful Twitter artwork so each one of
these images is creating using the text
from the author's tweets that's pretty
cool I guess
I didn't think it would be cool to do
the same thing with the top 100 Twitter
users by number of followers and I don't
want to wait as long so I figured out
how to parallel eyes my code I only have
access to a couple of CPU cores on the
server so it helps cut the time it would
take in half so it takes about seven
minutes to complete with a hundred
images and those two cores and basically
I'm ignoring all of Joe's talk this
morning on making things more efficient
I'm just throwing money at it so at this
point my imagination starts to go a
little crazy to see what I could do next
and I'm so I'm a gamer and I thought
it'd be cool to take a video of the
first level of doom
separate all the individual frames and
then recreate each frame with the port
this same portrait style using text from
the source code of the game so it seems
like a good use of my time right now
that was a lot of individual frames to
deal with it was about a thousand images
and I could take six seven hours to
complete even if I parallelize my code
and I'm restricted on the server for the
amount of CPU and memory and it would be
cost and efficient for me to have some
really beefy system doing something like
this but I do have access to a
kubernetes cluster up on Google Cloud
and this cluster is actually set up for
me to have a lot more CPU and memory if
you don't know what kubernetes is don't
worry about it we'll talk a little more
about it later
in each one of these nodes have 32 CPUs
120 gigabytes of memory and I've access
to use it on demand for some reason
because of its auto scaling ability I
could send the cluster this type of job
it´ll and then it when it's not in use
it'll scale back down thus making it way
cheaper to operate so if only I could
just use 25 cores or so and I can get
this done really fast there so there's
ways that I can do that but they can be
somewhat painful but nothing is fully
integrated within the IDE until now so
this is introducing the our Studio
launcher so I'm on a server that has the
launcher already configured and set up
and I have the ability to launch these
jobs on the kubernetes cluster right
from our studio all I have to get do is
go to the new jobs pane in our studio
which is new for the rst of 1.2 release
start a launcher job select my script
and whatever options I want don't worry
too much about the details here in this
case I'll choose 25 cores and I'll start
it the script will run in the cluster
and I can see the status and output in
the jobs paint this will be running
completely independent of my currently
running our session now I'm able to do a
much more intensive task in a much
shorter amount of time what would have
taken forever now takes about 15 minutes
with the 25 cores it doesn't really look
like you can see it very well but it's
pretty cool this might seem like a silly
example
the ability to launch our jobs on a
kubernetes cluster open that opens up
some neat possibilities you can see how
if you have an intensive job you can
utilize another process the environment
to speed up that analysis now that
you've seen one of the things launcher
can do let's talk about what at what is
actually going on we've added in two
additional layers into the system the
are cydia launcher is a separate service
this is independent of our studio server
and it communicates with a plug-in to
connect to these different environments
so what am I talking about with these
plugins so the core of the job launcher
is simply a framework for loading
external plugins which contain the
actual logic for communicating with the
jobs destination so how did these things
work together once your plugin is
configured and the our studio launcher
process starts it executes your plugin
is a process plug-in process is a child
of itself and communicates with it via
standard in standard out so what kind of
plugins are available so for the 1.2
release of our studio where we are
releasing three plugins local kubernetes
and slurm and side note on slurm plugin
is still in development and it's not
really ready to be played with yet but
it's going to be coming soon so what
about other plugins we're still trying
to figure out what comes next but we're
planning on adding more plugins and
later our studio releases but what if
you have a super-awesome processing
platform that you use in your own
company well good news is that you can
create your own plugins and here's the
documentation to do so and that should
have everything you need to get up and
running with whatever environment you
want to connect you so there are two
types of jobs you can want from our
studio the first is ad-hoc jobs and
that's what we were talking about in the
first example you can use the jobs pane
in the IDE to launch specific scripts to
run wherever the plugin is configured
for you might see that I snuck as a
Python job up there the job launcher can
also run Python jobs directly from our
studio
the second is containerized sessions so
in this example I develop my code with
an R session on the RCO server that
lived
that box this is where I wrote and
tested my script and it's the session
that's tied to the console and the IDE
then I launch the script as an ad-hoc
job to the kubernetes cluster but with
the launcher I can also develop and test
directly on the cluster with a
containerized session I can write and
debug the code interactively with all
the capabilities your code will have
when it runs that means you can
completely separate these our sessions
from the our studio server if you would
like and this is integrated within the
our studio UI so typically you have a
single server and everyone is forced to
use the same version or versions of R
and Linux dependencies and admin has to
maintain that box for those users if
they need updates or new software so but
with the launcher and containerized
session those dependencies don't even
have to be installed on the server they
live in the docker image itself so
various users could be using different
images with different versions of our
specific our packages installed by
default and this allows you to create
those truly reproducible environments
also these images can be shared and
distributed on docker hub or any other
container registry so on the same our
studio server user one can be running a
session with the docker image that
contains a specific version of our get
specific Linux Linux packages and user
two could be running a completely
different version of our and different
our packages installed in shared
libraries by default or one user can be
running a bunch of different types of
images for different sessions for
various types of work and these
dependencies are now self-contained and
isolated from other containers being run
so user can completely screw up
everything in the container and it won't
affect the others because of this
containerized session one huge benefit
is scaling so currently with our studio
server Pro if you'd like to scale you
have to set up multiple RSP nodes with
all the required dependencies and load
balance between them if you get more
users and sessions you have to provision
more nodes and reconfigure the group
things like auto scaling becomes a much
harder problem to solve if that's what
you want to do but using the launcher
you can let a container orchestration
platform handle of that scaling for you
as you can see here we have our SP
running on one server with the launcher
and the launcher
communicates with the kubernetes cluster
to create these containerized sessions
their kubernetes and has all that
functionality to do the scaling for you
so this allows you to just have that one
RSP server you could have multiple for a
resiliency but all the memory and
processing load is kicked to the cluster
and not on the RSP server itself now I'd
like to demonstrate launching the two
types of job from with our studio server
this includes ad-hoc jobs and the
container I sessions
so here's our SP running the latest 1.2
release new - 1.2 is this job's pain as
some people have already talked about
and right here I have a script that's
just a test script that prints message
it sleeps for a little bit and then
prints the our version string so in the
jobs pane
I have the ability to start local jobs
but on our SP and if I have the launcher
setup I can also start launcher jobs so
first I'm gonna start a local job with
this test script just to kind of show
you what this job's pane it works how it
works
if you didn't see Jonathan already
talked about it and so as you can see I
can watch the output as it comes in it
shows a progress bar and I can see a
list of all my other running jobs and
then while that's running I have another
script and this is my top twitter our
script which is the one I use to get the
top 100 Twitter users and I'm gonna
start this as a launcher job so as you
can see I've got a little bit different
options when I'm going to start a
launcher job I have the environment here
that I can choose my art script or
working directory just like a non local
jobs but then I can also name it so I
can name this our studio cause I can
choose the cluster that I want this job
where this job to go to
right now this this art studio server
Pro has a local plug-in and kubernetes
plug-in and so I'm going to choose the
kubernetes clip the plug-in I can choose
the amount of CPU and memory you can see
that it was defaulted to certain numbers
and I also have a maximum and this can
all be configured by an our studio admin
in the profiles so for this script I'm
going to run with 10 CPUs I'm gonna
leave it 10 gigs and then this is where
I can choose my image so I have a couple
images already set up on Google cloud
registry and I also have the ability to
choose other and choose whatever URL I
want for whatever image I have so you
can choose a docker hub image or whatnot
so I'm gonna go with this default
I've set up that I have dependencies for
the script and I'm gonna hit start so as
you can see it's now running it has this
little icon showing that it's a launcher
job instead of a local job I can click
it into it to see the output and then
it'll just continue to run so I'm gonna
go back to this test scripts and I'm
going to change this so doesn't it take
so long and then I'm going to run this
test script as a launcher job so just to
show off that you're running in a
different environment this current
environment that I'm in is running our
version three point five point one and
then I'm gonna start this launcher job
in a different image so this one
obviously doesn't need very much compute
power and I'm gonna run in a different
image so some of you might be familiar
with the docker hub image our base and
that will be running the latest version
of our which is our three point five
point two so I'll see what the output is
here
start the job look at the output and as
you can see in my current running
environment I'm running three point five
point one in this image is three point
five point two so you can see how you
can run different images with whatever
dependencies you have for whatever
scripts you want to run so now I want to
show off containerized sessions so treif
showed off this a little bit in the
keynote but if you go to the our studio
server Pro home page if you're not
familiar with this it shows your act
currently active sessions you're
currently running jobs or completed jobs
and I'm gonna go here to new to create a
new session and from here I have the
same type of options as I had before so
I'm gonna name this I'm gonna choose the
same cluster I'm going to use the
default two CPUs ten gigs of memory and
the same default image
so now this currently running RSP
session is running in kubernetes and not
on the RSP box so it looks exactly the
same runs exactly the same but now that
in a CPU and memory use is actually on
that cluster
so I have a couple frequently asked
questions here let's see how do I get
the launcher in plugins so for the 1.2
release the launch will come bundled
with our studio server Pro and it will
include those three plugins that we
talked about the releases available is a
preview currently if you want to
download it and try it out so will this
come to the art studio desktop and the
answer is yes it will but for the 1.3
release so what we're going to implement
the launcher after this release and then
we'll start working on 1.3 if you're
unfamiliar with what our studio desktop
pro is because it's only going to be for
the Pro Edition it's an enhanced version
of the IDE with enterprise feature that
we're shipping with the 1.2 release what
about other our studio products so the
launcher is something we eventually want
our products to standardize on and so
our CEO connect and package manager
we'll be integrating with the launcher
and future releases so to sum everything
up our studio job launcher is a separate
service bundled with our studio server
Pro it's available now as a preview
release the three plugins are kubernetes
slurm and local and you can do some cool
stuff with it like launch ad-hoc job so
you can run those computationally
expensive or Python scripts somewhere
else you can run these containerized
sessions so you can run an isolated
environment with all the desired
dependencies create reproducible
environments and this will help you
scale so it should make admins happy so
have some further reading here here is
the documentation for admin guide of our
students over Pro and then also the job
launcher documentation
and if you have any additional questions
you want to talk to us please meet us up
in the professional lounge thank you
very much
so we actually have time for a couple
questions if anyone has some let me give
you the the mic over here I'm gonna try
and throw it to everybody keep your head
down nice cancer okay I'm talking to a
cube about an admin as access can you
set the kubernetes clusters that the
users have access to individually
because like some users may need to be
in one region cluster in one region some
of the users and then other things like
that yes you can use the our studio
profiles to set like whatever clusters
have they have available to them as well
as what how much CPU and memory they can
utilize and so you can set those
restrictions perfect thanks I'm gonna
ask what happens to your jobs if our CTO
server crashes they'll actually continue
to run and so if our studio is able to
come back you should be able to
reconnect to them
I do you have a common line wearing of
the launcher all can I call inside are
do you have a while come on come on line
level of one hope the man line yeah oh
so we're actually going to be working on
an implementation with our our Studio
IDE package and so what we'll be working
on that you can launch jobs through that
package that our package